so good will hunting in the film is a
troubled mathematical genius and he
solved this problem on the blackboard
there are a few candidates for the real
Will Hunting come shall we shall we talk
about
Will Hunting solves this problem there
is an urban legend that's similar of of
a student who ran into his exam late and
he copied down the problems from the
board and he went and solved them and
the last one seemed really hard but he
kept working on it and he and he managed
to solve it and he handed in his exam
paper and then the professor rings him
that night saying you're only meant to
do the first few problems the last one
was an unsolvable problem
Oh you've solved it so that's an urban
legend great thing about that is that it
happened the real story of that is there
was a guy called George Danzig he was a
PhD mathematician and it wasn't an exam
it was a lecture he went into his
lecture and he copied down the homework
on the board cut these two problems and
he went home and solved them and he did
he handed the minute they did seem
harder than usual and his professor when
I was just throw it onto the desk will
you the professor and this is what
happened to Perry this is the true story
this is how he tells it wakes him up six
weeks later banging on his door 8
o'clock in the morning on a Sunday
morning saying can I write the
introduction to your paper because my
paper yes those two problems you solved
were unsolved statistical problems that
he's done he this is the first he's ever
heard of it this actually happened
George Danzig was his name and a year
later when he had to pick his ph.d topic
he asked his professor what he should do
and his professor said I'll just put
those two problems in a binder and we'll
call that your thesis maybe you have to
have done a PhD to understand how how
much I hate him right now and so that's
one candidate for the real Good Will
Hunting
there's another famous possible
candidate for this there was a guy
called William Sidis now he was an
American guy who was a child genius a
child prodigy he they said he had an IQ
of over 250 and at the age of 11 he was
giving a lecture at Harvard for the
Harvard mathematicians on
on some such he was touted as he will
grow up to be a great mathematician
someday he got into trouble
as a young man he he was he he carried
the red flag at the Communists rally and
so he was arrested and he was arrested
for assaulting a policeman and part of
his bail you hit a cop you go down yeah
yeah that's right
and if you're communist as well so part
of his bail was to get a job as a
technician at MIT which is kind of like
real hunting and to see a psychologist
and the psychologist that he had to see
was his own father who put him in a
private asylum which for a whole year
which he called mental torture when he
came out he pretty much swore off
academia mathematics and spent the rest
of his life taking some clerical work
office jobs working the adding machines
he quite liked he found it relaxing
quite liked the adding machines but
swore off mathematics for the rest of
his life it's possible that the the
story of William ciders that I just told
may have influenced Matt Damon because
they were both Harvard people so Matt
Damon went to Harvard as well and so
it's a famous story and he was a very
famous child prodigy so it's quite
possible but in the film what they
reference is ram anujan ram anujan
was this famous engine clark i had
talked about him before but i'll tell
his story properly this time he was a
mathematical genius again because where
he was in India he had very limited
mathematical education he only had a
couple of maths textbooks to work from
and only from this he was able to
reinvent a whole bunch of mathematical
results by his own he dropped out of
college because he was so obsessed with
his maths he was failing his other
subjects and he had to take a job in an
office
he sent his mathematical results to some
Cambridge mathematicians
Hardy who realized how important
how amazing it was and invited him over
to Cambridge if you want to understand
the relationship between the professor
in the film and Will Hunting then when
what I've got here is a quote from Hardy
about ram anujan I think it's an
important quote and I think it would
explain what's happening in the film's
era if I may read it from here
he said the tragedy of ram anujan was
not that he died young but that his
genius was misdirected sidetracked and
to a certain extent distorted the years
between 18 and 25 are critical years in
a mathematicians career and the damage
had been done
Ramanujan's genius never had again its
chance of full development he would
probably have been a greater
mathematician if he could have been
caught and tamed a little in his youth
he would have discovered more that was
new and of that no doubt greater
importance so that's what hardly thought
about ram anujan and if you have to
remember this if you see the film this
is how the professor feels about we're
hunting when they're at loggerheads when
when he's so concerned about his career
it's because there is this sense that
mathematics is a young man's game this
is how hard he felt about Rama nooshin
this is how the professor in the film
feels about Will Hunting as well so
another big thing in the in the film is
the Fields Medal the professor in the
film was it is a fields and medallist
winner if I get that right and this they
make a big deal of it they call it the
Nobel Prize of mathematics which is kind
of true they they give four of these
medals every four years and it is a big
deal in math there is no Nobel Prize in
mathematics and the the rumor that goes
around maths departments is that Nobel
didn't like mathematicians there's the
story that his wife ran off with her
mathematician which is not true because
he was a bachelor and he wasn't married
so it isn't true at all he
didn't value maths he was interested in
physics and chemistry and he wasn't
interested in maths that's why there is
no Nobel Prize in biology when you watch
Good Will Hunting does it make you feel
good about mathematics do you think it
does of because you're is it good for
mathematics that film yeah because what
it does is it shows where first lady
shows mathematicians are human beings
they're not portrayed as nerdy
stereotypes awkward or socially awkward
or anything like that they're just guys
with a job and that's what we are you
have two skies with a job we're good at
our job what's wrong with that and and
there are genuine personalities in there
you got the young mathematician who
doesn't appreciate what he's got there's
the the PhD student who's jealous of all
the attention Will Hunting is getting
we've got the professor who is a regular
guy even though he's highly regarded in
his field news with a very important
mathematician fictional though he is and
he's a regular guy he has his own
problems he has his own weaknesses and
it does show that we are human
you